we're going to london
today is the day
we get our visas
we have all the papers
they finally open up they were closed we
got an appointment good vibes
good vibes we're going to get our visas
right
today's the day
can't go wrong i'm not driving to london
one more time
ever in my life this is the last time i
drive to london
the last time
you here
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta do a countdown how will i know
when you start one more time
one last time
going to london
this is the last time this is the last
time
how does it feel amazing i will never
drive in london
the last time
we're going to get our visas now
we think we don't know actually so it
could be another time oh god
we'll see
[Music]
we're going we're going
we got approved i'm so ready oh so happy
it was worth driving to london
wait let me take a screenshot
i'm what's happening the dogs because we
left them in the car so now we just
gotta figure out how to get the dogs
there and i gotta sort out all my boring
taxes because everybody want my taxes
this is huge
we were only for like
10 minutes
but i can hear her kiss through the
phone
why did i put your phone there
you made it we're going guys we were
approved
you had water man
we're gonna drive through the tightest
part in london where the bridge is like
like that
and if that range rover hesitates for a
second
london etiquette
says you have to honk like your life
depends on it is it going
it's so tight
dude he was not hesitating i ain't i'm
gonna hesitate
just look straight felix you'll be fine
you'll be fine
let's go [ __ ] you london
it's pretty bridge though
i need to address this i feel like or at
least explain
we didn't want to bring our dogs through
cargo because
pugs already have difficult breathing
and we're not going to risk
their safety just because
because of that so the other option is
to bring them in the cabin which should
be totally fine but the problem is
every single airline's maximum weight
for a dog is eight kilos
edgar is 10 kilos so it needs to be
eight kilos with the carrier as well
and i swear i've called every single
airline in the entire universe even
though american ones have nine kilo i've
called them all up and they're all like
no he's too fat
so we're flying private jet because my
dog is too fat it is april 2nd i am
freaking out because
uh the last thing is obviously that we
need to bring in our dogs to japan and
that's uh a long process if you're
planning to do that you need at least
one year ahead
and we had that but then you know kobet
happened so all the vaccines expired
so we had to get a booster for them we
did this complicated process but now we
had to do it again
uh which is fine but the problem is the
lab broke down the wrong date so i'm
speaking with japanese immigration for
dogs and they're like here it says 15
but you wrote down 14. somehow the lab
wrote down the wrong date so i'm trying
to explain to them but you know they're
great i don't want to complain but it's
not it's not easy to explain these
things like they messed up the lab
messed up not me i was hoping i would
receive the email today but i think
tomorrow they'll respond and i honestly
don't know because we're not going
without our dogs so
so complicated
we're almost there
so after countless emails
weeks later
we're finally there i think they haven't
approved yet but i'm pretty sure
now we wait
today
is the last day we see friends
so we're going bowling is the last time
we see all of us we might meet people
outside but since the only thing
stopping us from going to japan at this
point is getting covered and we leave
technically 10 days 11 days or something
it's the only thing that can stop us and
it's not happening so we want to meet
old friends now and then
japan
and we can film hey we live around here
guys just so you know
it doesn't matter because we out of here
that's the first place we lived in in uh
brian [ __ ] you whoever lives there they
were the worst people that went from my
ass they were so stupid
they wanted to claim my videos because
uh i showed their wall and it's there i
don't have license to shoot and it's
like what are you talking about that's
the fire
the burnt down pier it still confuses me
that's the day i came here 10 years ago
why is it still here
and they built that stupid thing while
we're here why
it looks
like an industrial chimney
good vlog we're going bowling and then i
don't film it we're back and we're going
back now
but we saw our friends we had so much
fun right
this is uh now it's like kind of sad
because
we're leaving them
and we're having so much fun
but
in the next life you know
we can bowl again yeah this is a good
night uh we're still gonna see friends
but uh
you know it's part of the journey
say goodbye it's not always easy
we're getting there
we're getting close
are you fading out that was good no you
should have kept fading that was perfect
getting out we're leaving we're fading
away oh
just got the dog approval
five hours ago
we got approved
we're the dogs
what's that
oh she's not here we leaving two days
and we spent we spent all the day just
going through documents there's like
uh
dozens of papers for all the dogs and
it's insane bringing dogs over i
am
so nervous about it we saw last minute
that they want the original documents
and it's like oh i wish you told us that
earlier now we're kind of we got them
authenticated by our vet but we're kind
of i'm kind of freaking out like is that
going to be okay or not march is a way
of getting our covid test collected now
which luckily our kobe test came
negative because if
if they came positive we we couldn't
have even traveled so that's a huge
really but yeah this step by step so we
got one hurdle down we got many more to
go and that's just what we're dealing
with today i'm so tired such a long day
you guys are a lot of trouble basically
marcia just wrote me she got the forms
nice
[Music]
maya
i need to wake up we're going to japan
my out today's the day
i'm walking the fuggies for the last
time it feels weird
i always take a mental note whenever i
travel far like i'll think now and then
i'll think back here in like
20 hours i'd be like oh yeah
i used to be there
very nervous today anxious there's
always some hurdle to come past we're
i'm we're both concerned about the dogs
mainly
uh mainly maya really
trying to think positive it's gonna go
well today's the day look at
maya so glad she's calm
and edgar
are you excited
[Music]
are you gonna behave that game
yeah he looks like a good boy our next
move is cut our shares in half sell to
glockenstein and then we'll execute our
initial thoughts what do you think
[Music]
all right worth three hours
until we're done i think
just chilling with the
the dogs everyone's happy everyone's
doing well martial sleeping in the other
room which is a weird thing to say on an
airplane
hopefully everything goes smooth when we
land and um
a little nervous not gonna lie fingers
crossed hold your thumbs
that'll be okay
the first glance
of lane
my i guess a little morning
i wanted to put on a shirt for
all the immigration
it's my wedding shirt i got along
that's crazy god damn we land in 30
minutes
very exciting
i hope it goes well i'm still
[Music]
you guys did great
we're landing
we just left the dogs
they seem really really nice yeah so
they should be okay we have to do our
kobe test now we're supposed to spit in
this
why am i filming this
[Music]
i'm so happy
you guys are ashamed
we did it
why are you so calm
look at it
he's so sleepy archer yet lag
what's he doing
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's the end of the vlog
thanks for
coming along
we made it safe maya
she looks like
she wants some food
for so long we doubted whether we could
even make this move and we went through
all the
ups and downs and obviously it's been a
really long journey but i just uh really
really appreciate everyone
who were supportive of us going just
meant a lot that people were cheering
for us you know i i just want to say
thanks i really appreciate it it just
feels amazing to be here finally and
we're going to take some days to settle
in but yeah we can't wait for the next
chapter of our lives
until then